this was a written work autobiographical
that you helped to adapt for the stage
you played many yourself yes how tough
was it to make this into a film it's
been a long journey it's based on a
graphic novel like you said that I
didn't write but I first adapted into a
stage play and then into the film and
I've been working on the project for
eight years all told it's been a big
passion project something that I've
never felt kind of so passionate about a
project before in my life so each phase
was really difficult and I learned so
much about about the story as I went
along and all of the different
incarnations I did but it was great too
I got to know these characters so
intimately I'm getting sad now that my
journey with this story is almost over
actually this has been compared to by
some people and you credit catch her in
the Ryan this a kind of female Catcher
in the Rye well at what you intended I
never really set out to to make it a
female Catcher in the Rye I just had
this feeling when I read this book that
this character was so honest and so real
and was I related to her it was how I
felt when I was a teenage girl and I
just remember thinking this must be what
boys feel like when they read Catcher in
the Rye they have this character who
makes them feel like all of their dark
thoughts that they've had or all of the
things that they've experienced when
they were a teenager probably makes is
not so out of the ordinary they're
probably pretty normal the paradox of
this is that the the girl is 15 years
old you've made a movie about a girl who
couldn't be able to see the movie about
herself because of the rating for this
so your audience part of your audience
in a way is out of reach who do you see
your audience and how how what have you
been hearing in response early on well
when I read the book Phoebe's book I was
in my late 20s but it's still resonated
with me as I think there's something
about teenagehood
it takes a really long time to get over
our teenager it took me a long time
items working out here on the screen but
so I feel like that that time of life is
so potent and you go through so much and
it's so the emotions are so extreme and
I
think we get over it quickly so I feel
like for me and I think for a lot of
women who I've talked to this still
feels like us it still feels really real
and like if it's our story
I do hope teenage girls can see the
movie it's it's got a rated R here so
girls can go if they have an adult
bringing them at least and which is
better than in the UK it's got an 18
rating and people can't go even if they
have an adult with them they can't go at
all so it's a stricter rating there but
I I hope it's a movie that's not just
for women - that men can see themselves
in and relate to this female protagonist
I've been relating to male protagonists
for my whole life so because that's kind
of all it was on offer yeah talk a
little bit about the casting you have an
English actress for the lead yes you
have Kristen Wiig who met whom you know
known for a long time who everyone knows
is a great comic actress yes and
Alexander Skarsgard those that's the
triumvirate yes how did the casting come
about well I never thought I was gonna
cast somebody who was an American for
the lead actress but um Belle Polly who
is so incredible in the film she
submitted an audition tape and in her
audition tape she did her American
accent I didn't realize she was British
until she got to the end and she put a
little personal message in and went into
her normal dialect and she recorded just
this really sweet personal message
explaining how much the film meant to
her and she had never read anything that
she cared about in this way and she just
asked me to have a conversation with her
so it was such a random thing to get an
audition tape and I don't think people
often get cast from audition tapes but
it was so compelling and she was so good
that we started a Skype relationship and
then eventually I got her into New York
Goddard in New York and I had her and
Alexander sit down in a room and we
worked on a couple scenes and their
chemistry was so right that then that's
how that came together but yeah it's an
incredible cast and all three of and
Kristen I I was friends with Kristen
Wiig which I feel like such a jerk
whenever I say this like such a
douchebag
um I was I knew Kristen because my
husband worked for Saturday Night Live
for a long time so I had thought of her
for this part because I thought it was
such an interesting take such an
interesting choice
so different for her and I knew she was
wanting to do more dramatic work and she
was starting to take on really
interesting projects so I approached her
with it and I think I I think I gave her
the script and I was like just say no
you probably don't want to do it just
it's fine you don't have to do it at all
and I said just don't even reply and
then she read the script and really
liked it so that was a huge as I was
watching I think I thought okay Kristen
weeks so I thought I'm going to be
waiting for her to break out and do
something funny but after her first
scene I didn't really feel that way I
feel like she's just good you just buy
this as somebody stepping right out of
the 70s and we all knew that Mott that
mom who was not the best mom doing coke
with their daughters and stuff like that
at least I did I grew up in the Bay Area
and there were a lot of parents like
that and and then there's also the fact
that Alexander Skarsgard is committing a
felony yeah and so you're watching it
you're watching this girl come into her
own sexually but at the same time here's
the creepy 35 year old guy how the
balance and getting the performances to
work and that must have been difficult
yeah it was tricky it felt like a
tightrope walk kind of the entire time
of directing the movie but the the movie
is so told from the point of view of the
teenage girl and she doesn't feel like
she's a victim so it was important that
we didn't feel like that she was a
victim in watching the movie and so that
kind of became this guiding force
through everything was where is she
emotionally and how does that guide how
we feel at every scene so we talked a
lot about Alex's character sort of been
like a big 15 year old himself and
Kristen's character as well that's sort
of everyone in the movies 15 emotionally
and they're all searching and they're
all trying to become better
nobody's black and white nobody's
nobody's a predator or a victim it's
much more complicated which is what I
think life is like and then Minnie is
the only one who sort of grows a little
beyond her 15 year old self the rest of
them pretty much stay there what was
interesting how that how you navigated
that because here are these scenes of
very intense hardcore sexuality and yet
in the next minute you kind of recognize
your teenage self with your first
boyfriend doodling mrs. John Smith and
the margin of your
of your notebooks and and part of that
was manifested through the the
illustration mmm the graphic element oh
I had fun kind of playing with the
juxtaposition between I think part of
why teenagehood is such a painful period
of our lives is you got one foot in your
childhood in one foot in your adulthood
and I I had fun playing with the
juxtaposition with scenes and editing of
her kind of being like a little kid in
one scene and like a grown woman in the
next because I do think that oscillation
is what teenagehood is all about talk
about the animation a little and how
that it had to have come from the
graphic novel but how did it work for
the screen it had kind of a Peter max
quality to it so the book is written
more like a hybrid it's not a
traditional graphic novel it's written
like a diary with diary entries and then
it has graphic novel sections comic book
sections and then it has full page
illustrations so I kind of used that as
an inspiration to make the movie have a
hybrid quality and the idea was the 70s
underground comic book movement and
basing all of the drawings and the
animation because it's what many would
have been excited about and drawing on
are crumb and alien Kaminsky and GD
glitz and all of these really
interesting comic book artists that were
coming out of San Francisco at the time
so I wanted the in the animation to be
really tactile and feel hand-drawn it
was all drawn on paper I had one
animator who was really inspired by the
70s in her own work who hand drew every
frame of animation so it's hard to find
actually animators who do that kind of
animation these days and I just found
the perfect person and she and she took
the style of Phoebe's illustrations from
the book but she took them and ran with
them and she you know she filled her
notebook also she did all of the props
and all of the prop drawings and and
then hand her every frame of animation